fin d'après midi rémy prend son service
sac sur le dos il monte sur son vélo
électrique se met en ligne sur
l'application aux brics première course
de la soirée lors du compliment il a
triplé ses revenus il espère maintenant
une hausse des commandes pendant le
couvre-feu et compte sur les étudiants
il ya deux jours il ya des étudiants qui
m'ont demandé en disant est ce que les
plafonds seront ouvertes
voilà passé il ya là qui finissent à 8
heures le soir et qui seront commandés
remanger tout simplement
et j'ai dit oui voilà on sera l'art tout
ça alors ça les rassure c'est pour ça
que je pense que ça va marcher à vélo ou
même en roller
les livreurs sont partout dans la ville
et serait même trop nombreux entre 700
et 800 rien qu'à dijon un chiffre qui ne
cesse de croître et qui inquiète cyril
livreur depuis deux ans il craint ne pas
pouvoir bénéficier du s'ouvre feu plus
de l'ivresse de commandes mais du fait
qu'ils aient plus de livreur au final ya
moins de commandes par libre le ritz des
libéraux ou encore stuart tous les
courtiers inscrits sur ces trois
plateformes peuvent circuler et livré
des clients après 21h et certains
restaurants comptent bien en profiter
on attend beaucoup d'eux parce qu'ils
vont permettre de palier au niveau du
service de 21h à 22h en fait là où les
gens vont plus pouvoir venir sur place
le service de livraison
permettre de pallier tout ce manque à
gagner au final donc les gens vont
pouvoir rester chez eux et continuer
quand même de manger ce qu'ils ont envie
si elle n'est pas eu peur je pense que
ce serait beaucoup plus difficile pour
nous d'autres établissements en revanche
n'ont jamais fait appel au service de
livraison à domicile
c'est le cas de ce restaurant italien
pour le patron c'est inventons un manque
de confiance envers les coursiers je
vois souvent les mérites passé dans le
quartier
or moi je quand je vois les gars livret
qui prennent le sac qui pose à sac par
terre ou la marchandise même par terre
j'ai vu sur les à la juste à côté sans
intérêt spot pendant le confinement le
ritz avait attiré plus de 5000 nouveaux
restaurants partenaires en france
trois mille chez des libéraux